Years ago, our family became friends with another young family in our neighborhood.
The kids were about the same age as our kids and the mom and dad had a lot in common
with my wife and I. Well, as we got to know him, it was very clear that the father
who became a good friend of mine was not a Christian.
In fact, we had conversations about heaven and hell.
We had conversations about the scientific evidence for God and he was the consummate
skeptic. He always had a way out or a question or a
way of avoiding the evidence. And then years later, they ended up moving to the Northwest.
And when I heard that they were going to move, I had a couple of thoughts.
I thought, well, number one, gosh, he's no longer going to have me in his life and
other Christian friends in our neighborhood to talk to him about God.
And he's such a skeptic. He's never going to believe.
But then sometime later I started noticing he was posting quotes by C.S. Lewis
on social media. He was posting these Christian ideas.
To make a long story short, a few summers ago I had a chance to go up the Northwest
and baptize him because he'd become a Christian.
And on that same day his young son was baptized as well.
It was truly one of the most amazing experiences of my life.
I think there's four principles we can learn from this experience first
for many people coming to faith can take a long time sometimes even years
many people have emotional intellectual moral and relational issues to work
through this is certainly true for my friend before they can consider the claims of
christ second sometimes people are at a point in their lives where they're just not
open to faith. Even people walked away from Jesus in the flesh.
Years ago, when my friend was still skeptic, I had him speak into a group of my high
school students and I was trying to teach my students how do you have genuine
conversations with people who see the world differently?
And in the middle of this conversation, my friend said to my students, he said,
look, if your teacher Sean could give me evidence, I would believe.
I just don't see the evidence. And then in the conversation later, somehow it
shifted. I don't remember how, but somehow the group was talking about the
legalization of marijuana and my friend says he goes look the bottom line is I just
don't want the government coming into my house telling me how to live it's my house
and I stopped him I said wait a minute a minute ago you said you'd follow the
evidence now I think you have the answer why you don't you know Jesus says I stand
at the door and knock he's the ultimate governing authority God wants to come into
your house and tell you how to live you didn't want the government to tell you
whether you could smoke marijuana or not maybe the real issue is you just don't want
God in your life telling you how to live he looked at me and he says I don't
understand I tried three times to explain it and I gave up do you know years later when
he became a Christian he pointed back to that and he said Sean you were right it
wasn't a lack of evidence I simply did not want an authority in my life telling me
how to live friends sometimes people are not at a point in their life for a variety
of reasons to even be open to issues of faith third my friend
shared with me that back when he was a skeptic he had doubts about his faith now we
just talked about doubt and sometimes we tend to think that it's only christians who
have doubts but that's not true people of all walks of life and different beliefs
often have doubts my friend would go to sleep at night sometimes and wonder
is there really anything to this claim about God?
What if I'm wrong about my skeptical beliefs?
So the challenge for us is to ask the right questions to get people to doubt their
skeptical beliefs and hopefully come to Christ.
And fourth, relationships really matter.
It was certainly truth that was important in my friend's journey, but it was also
the love and relationship of believers that drew him in when his heart was open.
We've talked a lot in this study about how important it is to speak truth, but to do
it in a loving fashion. Jesus came in grace and he came in truth.
Yes, we need to speak truth, but from a heart of love and a heart of compassion.
In fact, we need to be willing to love people because they're made in the image of
God even if they never come to faith.
We have been on a long journey together.
We started by looking at the relationship between faith and reason and exploring
questions of truth. And then we looked at some different worldviews, pantheism,
naturalism, and monotheism. Then we considered the scientific evidence from DNA and
fine-tuning pointing towards an intelligent designer.
And then after that, we looked at these signposts that point towards purpose in the
universe beauty morality free will and story and then we examine the
specific historical evidence for jesus and for the reliability of the bible and then
after that we considered some of the biggest objections to the faith hell and evil
and in this final unit we've asked the question what now do you
have all your questions answered probably not in fact you might even have more
questions now than when we started but i want to impress something very important
upon you and it's this that you are ready you've been trained well i had a public
debate some years ago and i called up one of my professors from grad school and as
we were talking about it he said something to me i'll never forget he said sean
you've been trained well and the same is true for you you will always have
questions there's always new issues that arise But you have learned truth well and
you are ready if you put your training into practice to engage family and friends
and others of our non-believing world with the gospel.
You're ready.
Not only are you ready, but God wants you to step out boldly and put this training
into practice. You maybe have heard it said that with great power comes great
responsibility. This is actually a biblical idea.
Jesus said he who has been given much, much is required.
You've been blessed by people who care enough about you to take you through this
training. The question is what will you do with it?
God wants you to speak truth boldly and yet He wants you to do it with a heart of
love. He wants you to speak truth with compassion.
Friends we live in a broken and a hurting world that desperately needs Jesus.
We live in a world that desperately needs people to speak the truth about Jesus, the
only truth that can set people free.
The question is will that be you?